hello now we come to an award whose
previous winners include Jack Nicholson
Sean Connery Denzel Washington and
Javier Bardem just to name a few all
great stars were very proud to be called
Best Supporting Actor here are this
year's nominees for performance by an
actor and a supporting role
Christian Bale the fighter John Hawkes
Winter's Bone Jeremy Renner the town
Mark Ruffalo The Kids Are Alright
Geoffrey Rush the King's Speech
and the Oscar goes to Christian Bale the
fighter this is the first Academy Award
a nomination for Christian Bale
bloody hell well a roomful of talented
and inspirational people and what the
hell am I doing here
in the midst of you it's such an honor
David O'Russell what great spirit you
know on the set just just fantastic and
thank you so much me for making the work
that all of us actors did actually mean
something you know I mean that's the
director's job of translating it to the
audience or making it mean something
thank you for that thank you to pamela
mine
likewise as our editor the the just
incredible work of every actor melissa
i'm not going to drop the f-bomb like
she did I've done that plenty before Amy
Jack Marc man you know the guy who just
got this whole thing going right from
the get-go
everybody in Lowell all the actors from
there Vicki and Vicki where's Mike
wacker is he up there think he's out
there somewhere wait a mate you're the
best you're the best
I can't wait and listen he's had a
wonderful story and I can't wait to see
the next chapter of his story you know
if you want it if you want to be a champ
if you want to go train with him go meet
with in dick Eklund calm go do it check
him out okay all right it deserves it
our producers Mark David Todd incredible
relativity and paramount for just
pushing this out there and let people
know exist so many movies are just
brilliant but nobody ever knows about
them you know so we're so lucky to be
here tonight and have people recognize
that my team led by Patrick and boomer
and Carlos and Jane and Anna and Julie
thank you so much for everything you do
and of course mostly my wonderful wife I
didn't think I was like this I thought I
said my wonderful wife who's my masked
through the storms of life
I hope I'm like wise to you darling a my
little girl who's taught me so much more
than I'll ever be able to teacher thank
you thanks so much
you